اعلن مرشح الرئاسه ورئيس تيار المرده في
لبنان سليمان فرنجيه التزامه باتفاق
الطائف وبالاصلاحات المطلوبه لاخراج
البلاد من ازمتها عند وصوله الى مقعد
الرئاسه فرنجيه استبعد في حفل حزبي انتخاب
رئيس للجمهوريه في جلسه البرلمان يوم
الاربعاء المقبل مؤكدا اللا مشكله لديه في
انتخاب مرشح اخر للرئاسه اذا توافقت عليه
القوى السياسيه كافه
ملتزم بالاصلاحات ملتزم بالطائف بما فيه
المركزيه الاداريه يلي موجوده بالطائف
رايحين على انتخابات يوم الاربعاء
وكل واحد بصوت اللي ما بتطلع النتيجه
بس انا شايف بهذا الجو صعبه انتاج رئيف
انا ماني فارض حالي احدا ولا طالب شيء انا
اذا عبكره يتفق على مرشح وطني بيقدروا يحل
مشكله البلد ويكون بيريح البلد وفي اجماع
وطني عليه او اكثريه وطنيه اعلان احنا ما
عندنا مشكله